[Musik]
was nun herr scholz als finanzminister
und vizekanzler haben sie für den alltag
mit corona die formel der neuen
normalität geprägt wollen sie damit
wirklich sagen dass eingeschränkten
bürgerrechte das eine fast zum
stillstand gekommene gesellschaft dass
zehntausende bedrohte betriebe auf
absehbare zeit vielleicht für monate
vier jahre der normalfall werden nein
das gegenteil
aber wir müssen der wahrheit ins gesicht
blicken und die lautet dass wir so lange
wir keine therapeutische möglichkeiten
für schwer erkrankte haben die besser
sind als heute und solange wir keinen
impfstoff haben der uns vor der
infektion schützt wir einen alltagsleben
am wirtschaftsleben entwickeln müssen
das immer mit der realität des virus
umgeht denn was uns gelungen ist durch
den lock down ist dass das
infektionsgeschehen sich verlangsamt hat
das wollen wir beibehalten und trotzdem
jetzt stück für stück herausfinden wie
wir aber auch veränderte weise als
vorher unser soziales leben wieder
zustande kriegen können also jetzt ein
neuer alter kann man auf jeden fall
sagen viele bürger wollen sich
jedenfalls nicht damit abfinden ist das
normal ist die kanzlerin hat heute ja
von einer demokratischen zumutung
gesprochen können sie denn den bürgern
garantieren dass all das was jetzt
eingeschränkt wurde tatsächlich
zurückgenommen wurde
können sie das überhaupt wird am ende
doch mehr kontrolle bleiben als jetzt an
freiheit da war es geht ja nun wirklich
nicht um kontrolle sondern es geht darum
dass wir aufeinander acht geben
die regelung die wir für den
öffentlichen raum gefunden haben dass
man mir distanz zueinander hat damit wir
uns beschützen wechselseitig vor der
infektion dass wir nur einen kleinen
gruppen unterwegs sind wenn wir im wald
spazieren gehen oder wie auch immer das
sind ja alles regeln die nicht der
kontrolle dient sondern dem selbstschutz
und das gilt auch für das was jetzt an
neuer etikette entwickelt wird zum
beispiel beim einkaufen und den regeln
die jetzt überall festgesetzt worden
sind das heißt wir versuchen ja stück
für stück herauszufinden wie wir
daneben organisieren können dass beide
anforderungen gleichzeitig erfüllt
gesundheitsschutz und
trotzdem ein mit dem virus leben der
alltag stehen sie mit ihrem wort dafür
ein dass die demokratischen verhältnisse
die freiheit so wie wir sie kennen
wieder zurückkommt unbedingt das
garantieren sie das garantiere ich die
bewegungsfreiheit gehört dazu dass man
wirtschaftlich sie betätigen kann dass
man seiner freizeit nachgehen kann wie
man möchte
und viele viele andere fragen und
deshalb noch mal es geht schon darum
dass wir die beschränkung die wir jetzt
ergriffen haben als eine notwendige
maßnahme des gesundheitsschutzes
verstehen aber nicht als etwas das für
dauern
die bundeskanzlerin hat ja heute auch
kritisiert dass manche bundesländer bei
der wiederherstellung der normalität zu
forsch voran gingen und agieren wer
sollte sich denn da konkret angesprochen
fühlen armin laschet der große
möbelhäuser in nordrhein westfalen
wieder eröffnen will oder malu dreyer
die ein shoppingcenter in rendel falls
wieder aufmacht weiß ich nicht ich bin
der überzeugung dass wir eigentlich in
deutschland das ganz gut hinbekommen
denn wir sind kein zentralstaat sondern
umso stärker übrigens seit jahrhunderten
rührt daher dass wir ein föderales
gebilde sind mit vielen zentren und das
führt natürlich dazu dass wir jetzt
solche weitreichende entscheidungen
nicht nur unter drei leuten ausmachen
sondern unter ganz vielen aber ich
glaube die entscheidung wäre besser wenn
man sich umguckt in deutschland dann
sind die nicht alle gleich aber sie sind
doch sehr ähnlich aber sie finden jetzt
auch nicht dass sie zu forsch sentry
merkel gesagt hat wir tasten uns ja alle
voran das ist doch das was man ganz
offen aussprechen muss wir nehmen den
rat von allen experten entgegen den
virologen den epidemiologen von vielen
vielen anderen
und dann müssen wir trotzdem als
demokratisch gewählte politiker
entscheidungen treffen bei denen es
keine endgültigen wahrheiten gibt und
trotzdem müssen wir sie treffen und sie
haben ja ein paar indikatoren im blick
die auch immer wieder genannt werden
wenn man sich die jetzt mal vor augen
hält dann gibt es diesen reproduktions
faktor der unter 1 liegt es gibt die die
zahl der neuinfektionen die ja insgesamt
deutlich abgenommen hat es gibt nach wie
vor viele leere intensivbetten also das
gesundheitssystem ist offenkundig nicht
überfordert wäre das und das
man sich natürlich als bürger wenn man
all das sieht wäre das nicht doch jetzt
die richtige zeit etwas schneller durch
lockerungen zuzulassen
wir haben gerade lockerungen miteinander
besprochen und auch zugelassen
das führt dazu dass jetzt überall in
deutschland nacheinander
die meisten geschäfte wieder aufmachen
wir lernen was das mit sich bringt
ganz allmählich wird der schulbetrieb
wieder geöffnet die notfall angebote in
den krippen und kitas nehmen zu und das
ist ja der weg damit umzugehen dass wir
erfolge erzielt haben bei der
reduzierung der
ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit und
gleichzeitig wissen wir dürfen diese
erfolge nicht gefährt sie tasten sich
voran sagen sie herr scholz der
gesundheitsminister ihr kollege spahn
hat gestern etwas ähnliches gesagt er
hat sogar eingeräumt
es könne sein dass eine zeit kommt wo
man einräumt man hat etwas falsch gesagt
die große stunde des verzeihens hat er
etwas pathetisch gesagt wenn ich sie mal
ganz persönlich frage gibt es bei ihnen
augenblicke wo sie zweifel haben wo sie
unsicher sind ob die maßnahmen die wir
ergriffen haben wirklich notwendig waren
in dieser region sieht es kann bei den
schwierigen entscheidungen die wir jetzt
treffen überhaupt keine geben bei der
man sich ganz sicher sein kann
ich glaube das gehört zu der
verantwortlichkeit gewählter dazu dass
sie trotzdem entscheiden und dann aber
transparent darüber sprechen warum sie
welche entscheidungen getroffen haben
denn am ende nicht zur entscheidung
entscheidend ist ja viel
unverantwortlicher und ich glaube aber
wenn man das so großen und ganzen
anschaut und auf der entwicklung des
infektionsgeschehen es in deutschland
mit anderen ländern vergleicht scheinen
wir das nicht so ganz falsch gemacht so
nun heißt natürlich weniger lockerung
auch es gehen mehr unternehmen pleite im
moment die wirtschaft kommt nicht in
gang sie haben jetzt gestern abend im
koalitionsausschuss ja nochmal ein
weiteres hilfspaket verabschiedet
geschnürt mit mehr kurzarbeitergeld noch
mal mit mehrwertsteuer senkung für die
gastronomie insgesamt noch mal zehn
milliarden und ich habe extra noch mal
nachgelesen zusätzlich zu den bereits
zugesagten 303 und
50,3 milliarden die sie aus dem haushalt
nehmen wollen wie lange kann der staat
das eigentlich aushalten wie können sie
wie lange können sie das als
finanzminister verantworten wir sind
schon in der lage ziemlich lange
durchzuhalten
das ist auch die konsequenz der tatsache
dass wir in den letzten jahren eine sehr
solide haushaltspolitik gemacht haben
und das ist ja fast ein bewegendes
zeichen dass unmittelbar bevor wir jetzt
so viele mittel mobilisieren müssen und
mit den wirtschaftlichen sozialen und
gesundheitlichen folgen der pandemie
umzugehen wir es gerade geschafft hatten
alle kriterien der stabilität in
finanzieller hinsicht nach den
europäischen verträgen den maastricht
regeln zu erfüllen wir waren unter 60
prozent der wirtschaftsleistung als
staatsschulden aber wir werden jetzt auf
75 steigen nachdem was wir jetzt
berechnen können wo das genau endet das
werden wir sehen
in der letzten krise bei 80 ist das
zeigt mir sind ziemlich stark was unsere
möglichkeiten sie waren ja stolz stolz
sozusagen noch im januar fast wie
wolfgang schäuble
der herr der schwarzen null zu sein
jetzt sind sie wegen der notlage wegen
der ungeheuren summen die jetzt auf den
tisch gelegt werden der herr der roten
zahlen
gott sei dank doch jetzt wirklich habe
ich immer den zusammenhang hergestellt
und im deutschen bundestag und bei
vielen anderen gelegenheiten öffentlich
gesagt dass wir so sehr aufs geld achten
in guten zeiten hat einen vernünftigen
grund nämlich dass wir in schlechten
zeiten alle kraft haben die wir brauchen
jetzt haben wir sie ab 2023 sagen sie
jetzt sogar sie heute morgen im zdf
morgenmagazin nochmal gesagt wollen sie
die schulden die jetzt gemacht werden
zurückführen
das werde gelingen ohne zusätzliche
sparanstrengungen und ohne kürzung von
sozialleistungen denn fragt man sich ein
bisschen wie soll das gehen
erst mal kann man sich ja ungefähr
ausmalen worum es geht wir haben
oberhalb der grenze der schuldenbremse
100 milliarden euro zusätzliche kredite
bewilligt bekommen und diese können wir
in 20 jahren zurückführen und dann kann
man sich leicht ausrechnen dass das
jetzt gemessen an dem haushalt
ja jetzt normalerweise etwa 360
milliarden euro beträgt
eine überschaubare summe ist die dann ja
vier jahren nacht bleibt und deshalb ist
das eine plausible aussage dass wir die
möglichkeit haben dass wir nicht in die
krise hineinsparen müssen dass wir das
hohe investitionsniveau halten können
das wir geschaffen haben aber auch zb
den sozialstaat der uns jetzt in dieser
lage ja hilft und stark macht auch
weiter stark halten stichwort
sozialstaat sie haben gesagt beim
schuldenabbau müsse es gerecht zugehen
gehört dazu die reichensteuer die ja von
der spd gerne immer wieder gefordert
wird auch von ihrem parteivorsitzenden
höhere besteuerung für spitzenverdiener
obwohl es vielleicht gerade die trifft
die jetzt von der krise sowieso
betroffen sind zb die mittelständler im
augenblick wissen ja alle was ein gut
funktionierender staat mit einem
steuersystem dass diejenigen mehr
heranzieht die mehr verdienen zu leisten
vermag länder in denen das nicht der
fall ist haben jetzt ganz andere
probleme und deshalb glaube ich schon
dass auch nach der krise ganz anders als
vor zehn zwölf jahren nach der
finanzkrise 2008/2009 diejenigen den
milliarden geholfen wurde von den
steuerzahlern nicht hinterher sagen
damit hätten sie gar nichts zu tun sie
seien ganz alleine auf der welt
das glaube ich wird nicht passieren
darum wird schon eher ein solidarisches
gemeinwesen nach der krise da sein
wäre es nicht schultern soll sind die
die wir jetzt gerne die helden der krise
nennen können sie das tatsächlich auch
zu sagen also die pfleger die frauen an
der supermarktkasse die die sich um die
müllabfuhr kümmern etc
ich kann allen zu sagen dass ich mich
als politiker das jetzt auch als
sozialdemokrat dafür einsetze dass das
so kommt natürlich wird das demokratisch
entschieden aber ich bin dafür dass
jetzt nicht nur überall reden gehalten
werden über die leistungsträger dieser
gesellschaft die systemrelevant sind all
diejenigen bei denen in den letzten
jahren und jahrzehnten zu wenig
hingeguckt wurde wie wenig die
tatsächlich verdienen wenn es die
probleme an höhere löhne bekommen es die
pflegekasse nicht übernimmt dann
übernimmt der bundeshaushalt zum
beispiel beim thema altenpfleger das ist
ja der aktuelle konflikt
das versprochene geld her die 1500 euro
bonus so wie ich die sache jetzt sehe
sind wir in der bundesregierung einig
wie wir das machen wir haben
möglichkeiten die von den arbeitgebern
kommen von den pflegekassen und die
stabilität zu garantieren dass das am
ende immerhin haut ist dann sache des
bundes also sie teilen sich das herr
scholz wir reden über knapp 1,2
millionen das sind die rettungsgelder
für die da sind die rettungsgelder für
die eu noch gar nicht drin darauf kommen
wir gleich noch mal zuvor kommen wir zur
satz ergänzung die ja auch zu dieser
sendung gehört sie kennen das wir geben
einen halbsatz vor und bitten sie in
knapp zu vervollständigen
der erste lautet wer den start der
fußball bundesliga auf den 9
am neunten mal für möglich hält wird an
der diskussion aller ministerpräsidenten
und der bundesregierung und aller
innenministerin und innenminister und
des bundesinnenministers und andere
minister die für sport zuständig sind
teilnehmen es war jetzt ein langer
halbsatz sind sie dafür
sagen sie das ist möglich ich finde dass
es gut wäre wenn es mit dem sport auf
solche weise weitergehen könnte glaube
aber dass es über die frage wann ist der
genaue termin auch keine endgültige
wahrheit gibt und finde wirklich das
sollen diese runden über die ich eben
gesprochen habe diskutieren jetzt geht
es mitte halbsätzen weiter eine
schnellere und vollständige abschaffung
des solidaritätszuschlags
eine frühere abschaffung für über 90
prozent ist sinnvoll
das waren der karower es am ersten
januar in kraft tritt soll auch früher
gelten cursor ersten juli das war schon
ein vers haben wir schon lange als habe
ich schon lange hat vorgeschlagen das
hat noch keiner eingeschlagen aber wenn
einer kommt und sagt corona bedingt
irgendwie ich stimme zu und nicht nur
ein handschlag geben dann machen wir das
von der korona krise die cdu/csu in
umfragen viel stärker als die spd
profitieren kann ist kein beinbruch die
spd profitiert auch und sie werden noch
mehr profitieren in dieser situation
geht sowieso nicht darum wer als erstes
in umfragen profitiert sondern
wer ordentlich und ohne eitelkeit seine
arbeit macht vielleicht geht es auch
darum dass olaf scholz als krisenmanager
dann nächstes jahr auch die
kanzlerkandidatur der spd beanspruchen
kann
ich war ja schon dabei zu sagen es geht
um diese arbeit machen und nicht um
eitelkeiten das entscheiden wir wenn es
soweit ist
am heutigen tag sitzen wieder die staats
und regierungschefs der eu zusammen
wieder per video es geht darum wie man
europa nach der krise wieder auf die
beine hilft
die kanzlerin hat ja solidarität
versprochen sie tun das auch es wird
auch schon konkreter es ist von großer
einem größeren beitrag deutschlands die
rede und dass alles immer vor der folie
auch kommen dann doch noch eurobonds
kommen corona bond so richtig vom tisch
scheint die doch noch nicht zu sein es
gibt es in ihrer partei ja stimmen die
sagen ja das wäre das richtige zeichen
jetzt für solidarität warum sind sie so
ganz und gar dagegen ich bin dafür dass
wir über das diskutieren was wir tun
müssen und dann darüber diskutieren wie
wir das hinbekommen können der rahmen
der verträge kommt ran der verträge die
wir in europa geschlossen haben und
entlang dieser linie habe ich als
deutscher finanzminister sehr hart dafür
gearbeitet dass es einen europäischen
konsens gibt über ein erstes paket von
500 milliarden euro mit den
möglichkeiten der europäischen
förderbank der europäischen
investitionsbank 200 milliarden euro
sind das mit einer art europäischer
kurzarbeitergeld förderung 100
milliarden euro damit das was bei uns
funktioniert auch anderswo funktionieren
kann und mit über 200 milliarden im
rahmen des europäischen stabilitäts-
becher leer aus da fahren trotzdem darf
man ja nicht vergessen dass zu einem
gebauten haus über alle steine dazu
gehören diese drei gründung sind schon
einmal da und das ist ein ziemlich
starkes fundament für das was jetzt
passieren muss offenbar gibt es jetzt
das modell nicht anleihen aller staaten
sondern anleihen der eu kommission für
die die staaten also auch deutschland
zum teil garantieren ist das eine brücke
über die sie gehen könnten eine art von
haftung durch die hintertür
ich bin jedenfalls der festen
überzeugung dass wir diesen
wie der aufbau form er wirksam sein muss
man mit wiederaufbau geht im augenblick
sind wir noch in einer ganz anderen
situation nicht nur in deutschland
sondern auch in anderen ländern ist ja
das leben noch nicht so richtig wieder
gang gekommen das wirtschaftliche und
das soziale leben dass wir dort einen an
starken wiederaufbau forderung zustande
bringen müssen
meine feste überzeugung ist das muss in
verbindung mit den haushalten der
europäischen union entschieden werden
dann steht jetzt gott sei dank gerade an
die frage über den mehrjährigen
finanzrahmen also die nächsten sieben
jahre haushalte der eu und das ist ein
gutes ein guter zeitpunkt und ein gutes
instrument zu gucken ob man dadurch dass
man am anfang besonders starke
investitionsmöglichkeiten schafft in
einem längeren zeitraum ein weg findet
wie gewissermassen jetzt konkret
geholfen werden kann aber auch das ginge
ja dann im grunde in richtung einer doch
gemeinsamen haftung denn es wären ja
dann garantien die die
eu-mitgliedstaaten sozusagen abfedern
müssen garantien sind dafür nicht
zwingend erforderlich wir haben
verschiedene möglichkeiten wie die
europäische kommission kreditaufnahmen
vornehmen kann wenn sie das möchte einen
weg haben wir jetzt gerade beschritten
für dieses kurzarbeiter programm über
das wir eben gesprochen haben die 100
milliarden
das wird zum teil mit eigenen mitteln
der europäischen union garantiert und
zum teil mit garantien der
mitgliedsländer
aber man kann sich auch vorstellen dass
das was aus eigenmitteln der
europäischen union gewissermaßen möglich
ist viel größer ist als das in diesem
konzept zb der fall war oder überhaupt
das entscheidende
und wenn man das im blick hat dann
versteht man auch an welcher weg schalte
wir eigentlich in der frage europa
gegenwärtig stehen denn wir werden
solche großen solidaritäts pakete nur
machen können wenn wir auch einen
schritt weiter gehen in richtung
fiskalunion
das heißt jemand der so etwas tut der
braucht auch einnahmen und ausgaben
miteinander als europa und das kann
nicht dabei bleiben dass wir dann 27
völlig getrennte
hatten sind die nichts gemeinsam haben
auf diese europäischen ebene gehen und
reden dann von einer gemeinsamen
steuerpolitik es wird bestimmt notwendig
seien bestimmte sachen zu harmonisieren
ich will mal ein paar dinge nennen die
da wichtig sind schon lange bin ich
dafür dass es so dass wir als
mindestbesteuerung gibt im globalen
rahmen aber natürlich erst recht in der
eu
das wäre eine harmonisierung die dazu
führt dass es kein steuerdumping gibt es
gibt bestimmte einnahmen die man
gemeinsam haben könnte zum beispiel die
besteuerung von finanztransaktionen oder
wenn wir diskutieren über die frage was
emissionshandels erlöse betrifft zum
beispiel aus der luftfahrt oder so herr
schulz ganz kurze antwort am schluss
bitte werden von diesen corona hilfen in
deutschland auch in europa auch
demokratie verächter wie zum beispiel
profitieren
das ergebnis unseres gemeinsamen europas
muss immer sein dass wir ganz klar an
dem festhalten was für uns alle gilt
dass das eine gemeinschaft demokratische
rechtsstaaten und liberaler demokratien
ist und das werden wir konkret
besprechen müssen in all den
fragestellungen die eine rolle spielen
und tun das auch
das war was nun vielen dank herr scholz
vielen dank liebe zu schonen zuschauer
für ihr interesse ihrem fernsehprogramm
des zdf geht es weiter mit notruf
hafenkante
schönen abend noch jazz aus berlin
[Musik]